guten abend herr lindner danke dass sie
sich für uns die zeit nehmen
angela merkel die kanzlerin hat ja heute
herr maßnahmen für die nächsten acht bis
zehn wochen angekündigt bedeutet dies
dass der lockdown gescheitert ist ich
wundere mich dass sie überrascht sind
darüber
der kanzleramtschef hat schon im
november davon gesprochen da war noch
nichts von einer mutation bekannt dass
wir noch bis märz mit dieser strategie
fortfahren werden also mich überrascht
das nicht auch ohne mutation war mir
klar dass das cdu-geführte
bundeskanzleramt und herr söder die
maßnahmen am liebsten bis oster und
weiter fortsetzen
und umso mehr bin ich der auffassung
dass wir eine diskussion brauchen über
eine alternative krisenstrategie denn
die sozialen und wirtschaftlichen
schäden werden jeden tag größer
unabhängig von der mutation auch für das
bisher bekannte virus brauchen wir eine
andere form der eindämmung die mehr
öffentliches leben in schulen im handel
ermöglicht um die vorschläge dafür
liegen auf dem tisch
die vorschläge sind vielfach
unterbreitet worden und vom
cdu-geführten kanzleramt bis hin zu
herrn söder und herrn spahn sind die
regelmäßig diese vorschläge in den wind
geschlagen worden mit dem ergebnis dass
wir jetzt bei den hohen infektionszahlen
und den schweren krankheitsverläufen und
bei den betagten und hochbetagten
menschen sehen noch mal trotzdem zu der
aussage der kanzlerin heute die ist ja
hinter den kulissen gefallen im
bundestag dort in der arbeitsgruppe sind
sie wenn sie schon nicht überrascht sind
dass diese locker und verlängerung jetzt
so ganz langsam eingepreist und
angekündigt wird überrascht dass das
dann erst mal so hinter den kulissen
gesagt wird und eigentlich nur zufällig
auskommen nein das ist nicht zufällig
rausgekommen und das ist die übliche
methode
ist das der grund dass der impfstoff so
zögerlich angekommen ist dass der locker
und verlängert werden muss also ist die
langsame im stoff verteilung schuld dran
nicht nur herr weise ich glaube dass der
hauptgrund ist das obwohl zb die fdp
seit sommer des letzten jahres darauf
gedrungen hat die risikogruppen zu
schützen das nicht erfolgt ist frau
merkel und ersparen haben im bundestag
gesagt das ginge gar nicht die
vorschläge die wir unterbreitet haben
die wurden zurückgewiesen um dann
schritt für schritt doch zu kommen sie
haben ja heute herrn palma auf dem
titelblatt der bild zeitung aber um die
vorschläge die hat palmer in tübingen
umsetzt die sind in der bundespolitik
von der fdp bereits im spätsommer und
herbst vorgeschlagen worden also ffg
zwei masken an die menschen mit einem
hohen risiko abzugeben und zwar
verschickt mit der post ohne gang zur
apotheke
das funktioniert bis heute nicht taxi
gutschein statt auf den bus angewiesen
zu sein
um den kontakt zu reduzieren exklusive
einkaufs fenster zeitfenster wenn man
sich mit lebensmitteln versorgen will
das ist da ein risiko gibt das bestätigt
ja herr söder heute dadurch dass er eine
ffb zwei masten kriechen im handel und
im öffentlichen nahverkehr fordert ja
wenn er das so sieht dann müsste man
schon sehr lange vor dafür gesorgt haben
dass die menschen mit einem besonderen
krankheitsrisiko geschützt werden das
ist nicht erfolgt und für mich ist das
ein politikversagen und zwar mit
ankündigung war über monate im parlament
wurde darüber gesprochen vorschläge
wurden unterbreitet sie kamen entweder
nicht zur umsetzung oder viel zu spät
mit dem ergebnis hat ein ende nach viel
zu sagen haben und auch hohe
infektionszahlen aber nicht bei der
29-jährigen sportiven frau mit den
absolut absolut lmp aber vielen bürgern
geht es auch oft um angemessenheit
finden sie denn mit heim haben wir
darüber auch bei den richtigen fragen
unser kollege paraná
sonntag gesprochen finden sie denn die
maßnahmen bis ostern angemessen
nein sie sind nicht verhältnismäßig in
dieser pauschalität es muss immer
abgewogen werden einerseits der
gesundheitsschutz andererseits der
schaden der in sozialer gesundheitlicher
und wirtschaftlicher hinsicht entsteht
und deshalb ist es eine verpflichtung
des staates immer nach milderen mitteln
zu suchen um möglichst viel öffentliches
leben zu erhalten und gleichzeitig die
gesundheit zu schützen immer ganz
konkret verzeihung herr lindner ganz
ganz kurz konkreten und zu schließen
weil wir sind sehr schlecht bei
innovativen und kreativen maßnahmen wo
sind die luftfilter in den schulen wo
sind die ffb zwei masken
wo ist die intensive test infrastruktur
damit sehr weise denn sich leicht werden
ältere verwandte besuchen sich eines
tests unterziehen können meinetwegen
sogar kostenfrei das ist alles viel
günstiger auch finanziell
als dieser massive lockt mit diesem
großen schäden ganz schnell noch einmal
und ganz konkret was würden sie als
erstes auf machen mich interessieren vor
allen dingen die schulen also schulen
bis ostern zu das ist ja ein
horrorszenario können sich das
vorstellen was machen sie als erstes auf
kitas und schulen vielleicht für die
jüngeren schülerinnen und schüler und
die abschlussklassen zuerst auch nicht
bundesweit einheitlich sondern dort wo
es das infektionsgeschehen zuletzt an
dem hotspot ist es nicht möglich aber im
landkreis plön mit geringen
infektionszahlen bauen sollen da die
kitas schließen und das verbinde ich mit
einer konkreten forderung erweise die
bundesregierung sollte jetzt einen
stufenplan vorlegen was muss vor ort an
infektionsgeschehen erreicht werden
damit dort vor ort geöffnet werden kann
ich habe schon im herbst gesagt wenn wir
uns orientieren an 50 neuinfektionen pro
100000 einwohner in der woche um das
flächendeckend über ganz deutschland zum
maßstab machen zum alleinigen maßstab
dann werden wir bis zum sommer aus dem
locker und nicht herausfinden
und deshalb müssen wir differenzierter
mit mehr kriterien vorgehen
wir müssen vorgehen damit wir den
menschen wieder eine perspektive
gegeben es muss eine perspektive geben
vor dem sommer auf öffnung auf kita und
schule auf handel und auch auf
gastronomie nicht überall aber dort wo
es möglich ist letzter kurzer punkt
bitte herr lindner berichtet morgen groß
über ein brandbrief der griechischen
regierung an die eu dort geht es um
reisefreiheit mit im funk bzw
nur mit impfung an die liebe ursula in
brüssel adressiert also reisefreiheit
nur mit impfung ist das der richtige weg
über die frage müssen wir dann sprechen
wenn wir wissen ob menschen die geimpft
sind auch nicht mehr ansteckend sind
dann wenn aber klar ist dass geimpfte
das von gerichten kein risiko ausgeht
dann halte ich es durchaus für
angemessen zu sagen jawohl
hier gibt es die möglichkeit wieder
seine freiheit zu verwirklichen als
geimpfte weil man andere nicht gefährdet
wir sind bild und wir liefern dir deine
news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier
und vergesst bitte nicht unseren kanal
zu abonnieren